>> ♪ ♪
>> WELCOME BACK.
WE ALL JAMES COMEY LOVES THE
SPOTLIGHT.
THE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR IS GOING
HOLLYWOOD.
JEFF DANIELS WILL PLAY HIM IN A
4 HOUR MINI-SERIES BASED ON
COMEY'S BOOK CALLED A HIGHER
LOYALTY.
JUST WHAT I NEEDED.
MORE COMEY IN MY LIFE.
IS SOME SOMETHING YOU WOULD TUNE
INTO IT?
>> SURE.
I LIKE POLITICS.
AND SLEEP.
VEEP.
I WANT TO SEE WHEN THEY GET IT
WRONG AND WRITE.
HOW DIFFICULT TO DRAMATICIZE THE
REALITY OF AMERICAN POLITICS.
I THINK JEFF  DANIELS IS A
WONDERFUL ACTOR.
I SAW HIM ON BROADWAY.
DEMOCRATS HAVE MORE PROBLEMS
WITH COMEY THAN REPUBLICANS
BECAUSE I THINK HE CAUSED
HILLARY CLINTON THE ELECTION.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE CURIOUS.
THE THING ABOUT THE DONALD TRUMP
ERA IT'S SO ENTERTAINING.
IT LENDS ITSELF TO HOLLYWOOD.
A HOLLYWOOD PRESENTATION.
>> HE IS SUCH AN INSUFFERERABLE
FIGURE.
I HAVE HAD ENOUGH.
>> THE REAL STUFF THAT RATES.
WE ARE WATCHING IT UNFOLD IN
REALITY.
YOU CAN'T OVERDRAMATIZE WHAT
HAPPENS.
IT DOESN'T GET BETTER THAN THIS.
OF COURSE TRUMP WILL GET
IMPEOPLED.
-- IMPEACHED.
THE GUY PLAYING DUMB AND A
DUMBER PLAYS JAMES COMEY.
HOLLYWOOD HAS TO MAKE HIM THE
HERO TO LOCK INTO THE AMERICAN
PSYCHE HE WAS THE RIGHT MAN TO
TAKE OUT A PRESIDENT.
ONE THE REPORT COMES OUT THEY
MAY HAVE TO REWRITE.
>> DEMOCRATS HAVE A LOT OF
ISSUES WITH COMEY.
>> YES.
ANY CANDIDATE THAT LOSES THEY
NEED TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
IF THERE WAS ONE PERSON THAT
CAUSED THEM PROBLEMS, IT WAS
JAMES COMEY.
A PREMIER DATE HASN'T BEEN SET.
THIS WILL HAPPEN 2 WEEKS BEFORE
THE ELECTION OF 2020.
I WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE WHO
THE CONTRIBUTING PRODUCERS ARE.
THEY WILL GET PAID TO CONSULT
FOR THIS PRODUCTION.
>> WHO IS THE AUDIENCE?
>> THE PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY MAKE
IT.
NO.
IT'S LIKE WHEN GUYS USED TO
WRITE FOR GQ.
WRITING FOR THE GUYS AT ESQUIRE.
TRYING TO IMPRESS.
>> LIKE THE "WASHINGTON POST."
>> YES.
I THINK THEY ARE MAKING A HUGE
MISTAKE.
THEY NEED TO FOCUS ON HIM TAKING
DOWN THAT VICIOUS CRIMINAL
MARTHA STEWART.
THAT'S THE HIGH POINT OF HIS
HERLOIC CAREER.
GETTING THAT VICIOUS CRIMINAL
OFF THE STREET AND PUTTING HER
IN JAIL.OIC CAREER.
GETTING THAT VICIOUS CRIMINAL
OFF THE STREET AND PUTTING HER
IN JAIL.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THEY GET
WRONG AND RIGHT UNTIL IT'S ABOUT
YOU.
BEING AT FOX.
IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE HOW MUCH
IS WRONG AND HOW MUCH IS RIGHT.
IT'S PROBABLY LIKE 60% WRONG AND
40% RIGHT.
THERE IS SOMEONE PLAYING ME.
>> WHO IS IT?
>> I DON'T KNOW HIS NAME.
>> TALL, DARK AND HANDSOME.
>> I DON'T THINK HE HAS A
SPEAKING ROLE.
>> LURKING IN THE BACKGROUND?
>> YES, JUST A PR PHOTO OF ME.
>> WHO PLAYED RUDY?
>> NOT RUDY GIULIANI.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THE FOOTBALL PLAYER.
>> I CAN'T THINK OF HIS NAME.
>> WHO IS IT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> SEAN ASSTON.
>> NO, I WAS THINKING GODFRIED
THE GUY FROM THE PROGRESSIVE
COMMERCIAL.
>> PICK SOMEONE HEROIC.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY TOM